in this video you're going to learn
about the Law of Detachment and the law
of syllogism and we're going to go
through a couple examples together so
first of all what exactly is this Law of
Detachment well this is one of the laws
of logic and way you can diagram it out
just to kind of help yourself remember
it is if P then Q let's say that that's
a true conditional statement if P
happens therefore Q will happen so what
we can think of With The Law of
Detachment it's like two Quant you have
a hypothesis you have a conclusion
meaning if this hypothesis is satisfied
meaning this event happens it's going to
cause Q to happen the mistake that
students sometimes make is they'll say
oh uh Q happened it must have been
caused by P and that's actually what we
call an invalid argument sometimes it's
referred to as the converse error
because we're saying it backwards we're
going against the direction of that
Arrow it's like a river the river just
flows one way right right so this causes
this not the other way around so Law of
Detachment law of
syllogism you've got three statements
you've got uh or three quantities I
should say so if P then Q let's say that
that's a true conditional statement and
if Q then R let's say that's a true
conditional statement if P happens
therefore R will happen you can think of
it like the transit of property sort of
if you're familiar with that meaning
like you know P causes q and then where
this one uh ends up this next statement
starts off with that same quantity then
if Q then R happens so through this like
domino effect I like to call it if P
happens R will happen Okay so it's kind
of like if you pass your class or if you
pass your final then you pass your class
if you pass your class then you're going
to go on to the next course so if you
pass your final through that chain of
events you're going to go on to the next
uh Math course right so that's the key
let's go through some examples the first
one these are not mathematical ones
they're just kind of fun uh sort of real
life examples but you'll get the gist of
it if you get your if you get 12 or more
points on your driving record then you
will lose your license okay so you know
what points are like if you get pulled
over for a ticket of some sort right now
whatever comes after the if this is our
hypothesis right so you get 12 or more
points on your driving like record right
then whatever comes after then this is
the conclusion you will lose your
license right so basically if you speed
you know you're going to lose your
license right too many times right now
let's uh look at a so Joe lost his
license what can you
conclude well what do you think about
that one do you think that Joe got more
than 12 points on its driving record or
no this one you can see they're saying
it backwards they're saying if Q happens
P must have been the cause of it right
which is not true it's getting 12 or
more points is what causes you to get
lose your license losing your license
doesn't necessarily mean it was caused
by getting 12 or more points you may
have lost your license because you
failed to pay the license fee you know
like maybe to to renew your license or
maybe you didn't pass the uh vision test
or the driving test or some other reason
right so this is what we call an invalid
argument or the converse error but let's
just say in invalid okay we'll just say
invalid argument okay now let's look at
letter B Bob got 13 points on his
driving record what can you conclude
what do you think about that one well
look what's Happening Here a hypothesis
was satisfied meaning that this
condition of getting 12 or more points
on someone's license that's what
happened that's what Bob did what can we
conclude
Bob
lost
his
license right so that one is again this
Law of Detachment we have these two
quantities if P then Q say that's true P
happens then we can naturally make the
assumption that Q is going to happen
assuming that this conditional statement
is true let's take a look at the law of
syllogism now for number two we have if
you don't sleep more than 6 hours a
night your learning will be impa imped
if your learning is impaired then you
will fail your math class okay so let's
just assume that this is a true
statement I know it's not
Ironclad uh you know true statement but
let's just pretend for this example that
it's absolutely true so remember
whatever comes after the if this is our
hypothesis so if you don't sleep more
than 6 hours a
night then I should have wrote the word
then in here but it's implied then your
learning will be impaired that's the
conclusion now let's look at the second
sentence if your learning is
impaired then you will fail your math
class so notice what we have here we
have two statements and sometimes I like
to even abbreviate it like uh I would
say something like uh don't
sleep then we'll say impaired so you can
kind of try to pick like one or two
words then where it picks up on the next
sentence it says if your sleep is
impaired so let's just say
impaired then fail math class we'll just
say fail so notice where this one
statement ends okay like the conclusion
is the hypothesis of the second
statement so it's kind of like a
connector in a sense so this causes this
but then this causes that so through
this domino effect if you don't sleep
what's going to happen you're going to
fail your math class let's assume that's
true for this fun example okay let's
look at letter A Sam failed his math
class what can you conclude so what do
you think for that one if somebody said
to you Sam failed his math class what
can you conclude would you say that he
didn't
sleep a lot of times people do that
because they're just kind of thinking
like um they're just kind of making like
associations they say oh yeah these two
things are associated so yeah one causes
the other the other one causes the other
you know it's like there's no sense of
order to it or uh CA and effect or this
using the laws of logic right it's just
kind of free thinking you know about
it but let's look what's happening
they're actually saying that
this is happening backwards and that's
what we call an invalid argument right
so this is invalid Sam uh could have
failed his math class because he didn't
show up for the final or he didn't show
up at all or he didn't study or he was
caught cheating on his test or who knows
however many other possibilities right
but the main thing is that we we're not
we don't have this domino effect where
the one event is causing the next and
then that next one picks up and it
causes the third and so through that
chain of events right let's look at
letter B now
Tom only sleeps four hours per night
what can you conclude look what's
Happening Here Tom doesn't sleep very
much right and to be more specific he's
sleeping less than the six hours per
night so that means that his you know
his ability to learn is going to be
impaired and if his learning is impaired
we know that means that he's going to
fail his final or he's going to fail his
math class right so in this case because
this initial condition this initial
statement was fulfilled that means that
this chain of events is going to be
triggered this is the law of syllogism
and we know that Tom is going to fail
his math class Tom fails math okay now
is that is that really true no maybe is
one of those people that can subsist on
three or four hours a night and he's
fine that's just how he's built and U
that's great these are just kind of fun
life examples but when it comes to like
a mathematical example and if a
statement is actually true these laws
are going to work as we discuss so if
you want to see more examples you want
to practice you want to test yourself
which I highly recommend follow me over
to another video I did talking about Law
of Detachment law of syllogism pause
that video and see if you can test
yourself and I'll see you over in that
video